current chief correspondent for the
sydney morning herald next he talks
about the failed poisoning of khalid
michal by the israelis in 1997 and his
subsequent rise to the top leadership
position in hamas the event hosted by
the world affairs council in san
francisco is an hour
welcoming me in your beautiful city
because of
where i'm staying uh
was to be able to come to the city this
morning by a ferry
uh which was a
lovely way to uh to arrive in town and
uh and see the bay the bridge and where
you all live
um
that is a slightly intimidating uh
personal side to it in that uh this is
the first time ever in about 10 years of
uh
talking to a forum such as this that
i've had some members of my own family
in the audience um
so i'll take that as it comes
but thank you all for coming
first of all i'd like to give a broad
look at hamas
where it fits into the middle east
crisis
how it has evolved
i expect that you one of the wondrous
things about hamas and the middle east
crisis generally is that
people all have their pet aspect of the
crisis on which they want an explanation
they want an understanding they want
some light shed or they want to shed
some light of their own and that comes
through in question so
what i'll do first is to set out
where i see it after
virtually two years of intense
immersion
in hamas and also in the the crisis
generally
you'd have to say that it's truly
remarkable that for more than six
decades
the palestinian crisis has been such an
enduring element of u.s foreign policy
one that imposes itself on president
after president
defeating administration after
administration
for a good deal of that time yasar
arafat was the best known though not
necessarily the best understood leader
of the palestinian people
for much of that time he was treated as
an enemy
at others a sometimes ally
always indefatigable arafat was observed
by the west with both frustration and
admiration
as he slipped and slid between the
layers of his own personal and political
complexity
he was the one man band who
single-handedly created and then took us
his own
the powerful fatah movement
and the plo
for all his failings all his foibles
it was arafat who kept alive the flame
of palestinian nationalism
but for the last 20 years
a parallel palestinian force was
emerging
known to us today as hamas this
organization's first few years were
devoted to secret underground planning
it was not till the harrowing early days
of the first intifada in 1987 that this
determined new movement burst upon the
palestinian scene
launching itself on a trajectory by
which
it finally and undeniably overhauled and
overwhelmed the fractured remnants of
arafat's fatter movement
to become the most distinct most
organized and the most efficient
nationalist voice in both the west bank
and the gaza strip
for all that
hamas was shaped
and is led today by a man who outside
the circles of the middle east cognizant
is hardly known in western capitals
khalid michal was a child in a village
called silwad in the jerusalem mountains
on the west bank in the late 196 in the
1950s when arafat was girding himself
for war against israel
with the exception of a brief holiday
return to the west bank as a student in
1975
michelle
has not been back to the occupied
territories since the days after the six
day war in 1967
his family fled
driven by a by fear of a repeat of the
israeli excesses of 1948.
they joined tens of thousands who took
flight compounding a pre-existing
palestinian refugee crisis that already
had become a linchpin in regional and
cold war politics and policy
michelle's family resettled in kuwait
where by age 11
he was an avowed nationalist
by age 15
he declared himself to be an islamist
adopting the strict spiritual regimen of
the muslim brotherhood
the 1920s egyptian islamist movement
which inspires much islamic resistance
and terrorism even today
at that time
according to one of his brothers
michelle became something of a religious
enforcer in the family home
checking daily on who had said their
prayers and giving them a whack when
they hadn't
as a physics student at kuwait
university in the 1970s michelle went
head to head with the secular fata
controlled palestinian student union
challenging its mortgage on control of
all things palestinian
in the 1980s
michelle's work as a physics teacher in
kuwait provided him with excellent cover
for his covert activities on behalf of
the movement that was to become hamas
it was an underground cell led by michal
that devised the plan for an islamist
oriented jihad in the occupied
territories
a move that amounted to a declaration of
war
on yasser arafat as much as on israel
during these underground years michelle
revealed a flare for fundraising on a
grand scale
at the same time he proved to be a sound
disciple of a warrior preacher called
sheikh abdul azam
who will be better known to some of you
for his mentoring of osama bin laden
azam's regular travels between pakistan
and afghanistan and the middle east it
always included transit stops in kuwait
city much of which was spent at the home
of khalid michal
teaching his host the dark art of jihad
the management of resistance and the
sense of being a government and a leader
in exile
the amalgam that emerged from all of
this is an international movement which
today is controlled by khalid michal
from the southern suburbs of damascus
the syrian capital where he operates
from a dusty bunker festooned with
security cameras
hamas became a nationalist and a
religious movement that would eclipse
out of fat his father movement and the
plo
hamas was better organized more
frightening in its tactics more resolute
hamas would not renounce violence
it would not recognize the state of
israel
by its worldview there was eminent logic
in its stand
the palestinian people were acutely
aware that in making both these gestures
to an american-sponsored peace process
yasser arafat had achieved nothing for
his movement or for the palestinian
people
hamas contributed to that stalemate for
the palestinians with its waves of
brutal suicide bombings
but so too did successive israeli
governments which played fatah and hamas
against each other
demanding that as israel's partner in
peace arafat must guarantee israel's
security by putting a stop to the hamas
bombs
but at the same time israel refused to
deal with arafat
either because of the excesses of the
hamas violence
or
because of arafat's own backsliding when
he felt threatened by the rise of hamas
frequent error in western attempts to
understand hamas was a failure to grasp
the organizational breath of what was a
global movement
with its roots deep in palestine the
palestinian diaspora and other islamic
communities around the world
because hamas was seen to have emerged
from the cauldron of the intifada in
gaza and to be under the local
leadership of the revered gaza holy man
sheikh ahmed yasin
it was not until after the horrors of
the september 11 attacks on new york and
washington that authorities in the u.s
and in europe
made serious attempts to corral the
terrorists in their own backyards
just how hamas survived for as long as
it did in the us
is one of the more surprising elements
of a worldwide story the worldwide story
of these radical islamists
i want you to picture washington dc
in your minds put yourselves on the mall
at the foot of the washington monument
a few hundred yards away on pennsylvania
avenue is j edgar hoover building
home to the fbi
just a few doors up is the u.s
department of justice
maybe 12 miles to the northeast the cia
headquarters at langley virginia
all points covered you would have
thought
but just a few miles south from the cia
is leafy falls church
over the state line in virginia but
still a part of greater washington
that's where a man called musa abu
marzuk lived in the late 1980s and the
early 1990s
on south sixth street
apart from him observing him mowing his
lawns occasionally the neighbors knew
nothing
the authorities even less
abu marzuk was a renter no driver's
license no property tax his business
card named the firm but stated no line
of business
his company was not registered locally
in the phone book it was unlisted
yet in america this was mr hamas
living in the shadow of the washington
monument
turning millions of dollars through his
bank account abu marzuk was a big wheel
in the hamas fundraising machine
but he was more than that
when israel demolished several layers of
the hamas leadership in the occupied
territories in 1989
abu marzuk dropped his doctoral studies
in the u.s to dash to gaza where he
steadied and rebuilt the movement's
reeling leadership and its vital funding
channels from abroad
moved up and down the gaza strip handing
out checkbooks for an account at the
bank of america
in which he had pre-signed all the blank
forms
when they needed cash hamas operatives
merely had to fill in the amount they
required and get the checks presented at
any bank in the region
abu marzuk though was only was not the
only senior hamas figure operating from
a u.s base
in 1993
the fbi thought it had hit the jackpot
with information on a group of
high-ranking hamas operatives and
sympathizers who were planning a secret
conference at the most unlikely of
venues
the courtyard marriott hotel just off
the delaware expressway next to
philadelphia international airport
the bureau had the place wired
every word spoken was laboriously
transcribed
even complaints by some of the delegates
about donuts instead of bread and hummus
for breakfast
fbi photographers were in the shrubbery
snapping everything that moved
the american authorities piled up the
information from philadelphia and
endless other investigations
but they didn't seem to know what to do
with what they had
finally
it was in 1996
a complex investigation was established
in chicago under the name vulgar
betrayal
but it became so cumbersome it caved in
on itself
hamas fundraising had become a part of
the american charity establishment
its front organization sucked in
millions of dollars at fundraising
events in american cities with big
muslim communities
one of the star turns at these events
was a song and dance troupe led by a man
by the name of mufud abdul qadar
who by day was a double degree engineer
employed by the dallas city council in
texas
and who by birth was a brother of the
hamas leader khalid michel
it took the jolt of nine at the 911
attacks and groundbreaking civil legal
work by the washington lawyer nathan
lewin to break the logjam
but it was not until just four months
ago that the authorities finally won
substantive terrorism convictions
against a group of hamas fundraisers in
the united states
fifteen years after the breed without
hummus breakfast at philadelphia and
almost twenty years after musa abu
marzuk was parachuted into gaza
showering the local hamas leadership
with signed blank checks drawn on an
american bank account
despite setbacks in the u.s jurisdiction
and to lesser degrees in the middle east
and in europe hamas thrives
notwithstanding the best efforts of the
israeli government and its security
forces
along with those of the united states
and the remnants of arafat's fata
movement
today father is led by mahmoud abbas
a lackluster individual who has
inherited arafat's leadership mantle
but who conducts himself more according
to his own needs than those and those of
an aging fatter clique with which he
must march in lockstep than he does with
the nationalist aspirations of his
people
abbas like many of his lieutenants sees
himself as a fatah man
engaged in a war of near tribal
proportions with hamas
before he sees himself as a leader of
all palestinians confronting or
negotiating with israel
on the west bank and in gaza on their
behalf
the middle east crisis might have been
played differently
in the aftermath of its annexation of
gaza and the west bank in 1967
israel could have negotiated with
jordan's king hussein
and because it didn't
it ended up confronting being confronted
by arafat and the plo
and because israel refused to deal
meaningfully with arafat it was faced by
hamas
in refusing to deal with hamas we can
only wonder about the nature of the
movement that might supplant today's
islamists
it's worth noting
that for all the talk and all the
seeming participation in peace processes
israel has conceded virtually nothing
since nineteen forty eight
and more recently since nineteen sixty
seven
against a backdrop of u s managed
on-again off-again dialogue
the reality of the process is that more
and more palestinian land has been taken
for more and more israeli settlements
roads and checkpoints
all of which serve to shrink palestinian
hope and dignity
through this innovating process hamas
has fought its way to a seat at the top
table
be it recognized as a player or not
any doubt about its status evaporated
after the dramatic intervention in 1997
of president bill clinton
in the race to save the life of khalid
michal
after israeli agents injected him with a
secret poison in the streets of armaan
in the region
hamas is seen as a legitimate player
outside the middle east more often than
not it is denied legitimacy
and designated as a terrorist
organization although significant cracks
now are emerging in what for years was a
firm united stand by the united states
and europe
all too often the middle east diplomacy
focuses on the geopolitics
and on the leadership frictions and
factions and on how they might be played
one against the other
instead of focusing on the human rights
of ordinary citizens who on both sides
are trapped in a security void
what western analysts categorize as
extremism
palestinians describe as desperation or
hopelessness
these are sentiments that rise and fall
according to the fluctuating levels of
their faith in what they are told over
and over again
is a fair peace process
a process by which their rights will be
acknowledged and protected
working against them is a massive spin
operation which has varying degrees of
success in stopping the clock
for instance
we were asked to accept that the recent
gaza conflict was caused by hamas
rockets alone
and that israel's conduct in the
preceding months simply was not an issue
for all the squabbling on how the gaza
truce was breached through the latter
half of last year and by which party
hamas and israel actually did agree to a
six-month ceasefire
which hamas more or less held to
despite its view that israel did not
keep its side of the deal
there was no agreed text
this was an indirect understanding
arrived at through talks by negotiators
for hamas and israel who met separately
with egyptian middlemen
israel believed that hamas had agreed to
stop the reign of rocket fire from gaza
into nearby israeli communities
hoping to breathe some life back into
gaza's comatose economy hamas understood
that in exchange
israel would open the border crossings
into gaza ending a siege that had been
in force for more than two years
figures quoted by the new york times
indicate that the rate at which rockets
were fired from israel was reduced by as
much as 80 to 90 percent
as hamas curbed its own fire and that of
the lesser militia groups in gaza
in comparison
the number of trucks that israel allowed
to enter gaza increased only marginally
by closing the border crossings
israel stops the movement of goods fuel
and people
often allowing a trickle of movement
that imposes a level of hardship that
say for what is smuggled in through
tunnels from egypt amounts to a total
economic lockdown
under the june ceasefire deal the daily
rate of trucks entering gaza did
increase
but only from about 70 a day to about 90
a day which according to the new york
times figures was well short of a
pre-siege delivery rate of 500 to 600
trucks a day
opinion polls taken in the occupied
territories
and it's important to state that it's in
both gaza and in the west bank since
israel invaded gaza in christmas week
reveal an interesting story
in terms of the response of ordinary
palestinians to the january onslaught by
the israel defense forces
the jerusalem media and communications
center found that virtually half of its
sample of voters believed that hamas had
defeated israel
it's one of the problems with
insurgency and resistance movements that
a resistance movement
doesn't have to win to win it only
merely has to not lose as long as it's
still standing in the eyes of its own
supporters it is still winning because
it's still there so hence this belief
that that hamas had won
a separate poll by the palestinian
center for policy and survey research
found that 60 plus percent
of palestinians favored
further abductions of israeli troops
and they wanted to keep the rockets
firing on israel
the same poll showed that the deposed
hamas prime minister ishmael haniya had
outstripped washington's ally and fatah
leader mahmoud abbas as preferred as
palestinian president
and that hamas had closed the gap
between itself and fatah by half
the logic of the israeli attack on gaza
was to diminish if not to destroy hamas
but these poll findings indicate that
what they achieved was the exact
opposite
whether the rest of the world likes it
or not the parties in the middle east
crisis locally are israel
less so abbas fatah and more so khalid
michal's hamas
u.s foreign policy inevitably entwined
is entwined here too
along with that of the united nations
europe russia
which together with the us make up that
diplomatic oversight body known as the
middle east quartet
when it comes to the middle east
question
what michelle initiates from damascus
shapes the stage on which barack obama
and hillary clinton operate
either by their silence
or in what so far has been a cautious
commentary that has done little to lift
palestinian expectations of the new
administration in washington
khalid michal does not articulate it as
such
but when he is made to examine recent
history
as i asked him to do during almost 60
hours of interviews while researching
kill khalid
he seems to keep a mental ledger
on one side
he adds up the many mistakes of israel
fatah and the united states as they have
tried to tame or to defeat hamas
on the other side of this ledger
michelle notes the moves made by hamas
as it has guardedly moved towards a
middle ground
hamas is a resistance organization but
it is a resistance organization in
transition
and in transition it is
it is only so up to a point
in keeping with its own agenda
its own world view
not that of israel the quartet or the
world
the mistakes or the miscalculations made
by israel and the united states which
helped hamas to become the force that it
is today
are covered in detail in the book but
let me skip through some of the
highlights
in the 1980s
israel encouraged the emerging islamist
movement in gaza
believing that it would serve as a foil
for arafat and his father movement
in the early 1990s israel deported
hundreds of hamas activists to where
to southern lebanon
where they learned the art of terror
from hezbollah
in the mid-1990s american authorities
arrested musa abu mazuk
an unusually u.s friendly hamas figure
at the time
the leadership vacancy created by his
detention for two years in manhattan
became a stepping stone
for the more hardline khalid michal to
make his move for the leadership of
hamas as an organization
in september 1997
israel refused to consider an offer that
came with the impromature of the
venerable king hussein of jordan
to negotiate a decades-long cease-fire
with hamas
a few days later still in september 1997
the mossad's bungled attempt
to assassinate khalid michal in the
streets of ahman
at the time u.s diplomats in the region
were reporting to washington that hamas
was on its knees under the weight of a
crackdown by the combined forces of
israel
and arafat's palestine authority
in the wash up michal survives a hero
and israel is forced to release dozens
of palestinian prisoners
most amazingly of all among them was
sheikh ahmed yasin
the crippled wheelchair-bound spiritual
leader of hamas
who virtually all palestinians by then
had resigned themselves to seeing die in
an israeli prison cell
in truth hollywood could not have come
up with a more amazing plot
in 2005 the bush administration ignores
israel's pleas that hamas be made to
renounce violence before it can stand
candidates in the palestinian elections
hamas campaigns ballot in one hand bomb
in the other
with the blessing of george w bush
to the amazement of observers on all
sides hamas wins complete control of the
palestinian government
2006
washington and israel cling to mohammed
abbas feeble fatter movement as the
battering ram with which it plans to
defeat hamas
but hamas survives
despite diplomatic isolation and a
constant israeli military campaign
despite being challenged by an american
trained and funded fatah security force
which hamas whipped in less than a week
and despite a global act of collective
punishment for all 1.5 million garzans
as a penalty for how they express their
democratic will
and despite israel's massive assault on
gaza after christmas just
gone much of the research for kill
khalid was done in the latter half of
2007.
i was in israel between what ought to
have been grand celebrations
in june that year
israel marked the 40th anniversary of
the six day war and its conquest of both
the west bank and gaza
great planning was underway too to
commemorate the 60th anniversary in may
last year of the founding of the state
of israel
for israelis these were so these
celebrations were meant to be great
monuments to centuries of jewish
struggle and survival
but after 40 years of blood and cemetery
israel had achieved neither the security
it craved
nor total control of the land to which
its people felt entitled
by clinging to the illegal settlements
it had created the justification for the
harsh security regime that encircled
millions of increasingly embittered
palestinians and left many of its own
citizens living a reality tinged with
fear and anger
forty years on
as israeli analysts don't want to say
israel still was fighting the last day
of the six day war
now sandwiched between those two israeli
anniversaries is a milestone for hamas
the 20th anniversary of the founding of
the movement
in those two decades hamas had withstood
everything that israel fatah and the
world had thrown at it
hamas had defied all the early
predictions of its demise
israel's deportation of its senior
leadership in 1992 was thwarted by hamas
careful attention to succession planning
fatah power brokers were forever
claiming that the movement would
splinter as pushy young militants
overran the cautious old guard of the
muslim brotherhood
they were wrong
israel's targeted assassination and
arafat's crackdowns had broken neither
the spine nor the spirit of hamas
on the israelis assassination of sheikh
ahmed yasin in 2004
israeli commentators insisted that there
would be a leadership void in which the
young turks would tear the movement
apart
they too were wrong
despite the focused strategic efforts of
israel and the united states and the
overwhelming impact of worldwide
sanctions hamas has held together
a senior fatah leader who's well placed
to observe hamas in the occupied
territories
sees what he describes as
differences in governance and effective
control within the movement
however when he shared a late night
coffee with me in amman he told me
but in hamas this does not go to dissent
or mutiny i'm looking he went on
and i just don't see it
and yet the islamist movement of today
is very different to the angry and
sometimes ugly group that emerged in
1987
with hindsight hamas over time
has been revealing itself as that
movement in transition
the emphasis in its discourse
has shifted subtly
from jihad to hudna
or ceasefire
its territorial claims have shifted
from a resumption of the land which ran
from the river to the sea
to a two-state solution
based on the 1967 border
the target has become the israeli
occupation
less than it is judaism
to all of this there was a response
inevitable you might think
one of the first powerful voices to
accept that hamas needed to be brought
in from the cold was ephraim halevi a
former director of the mossad no less
authoritative voices in the united
states added weight and prestige to his
calls
and it's worth
pausing just to think of how halevi
expressed
his sense of what hamas was about
he did it thoughtfully considerably in
his memoirs at the end of a long career
always on the front line of security for
israel
the israeli security services and the
point that he made was that hamas simply
could not be acquainted with al-qaeda
and his rationale was this
al qaeda wants to destroy the system
hamas he argued wants to be a part of
the system
that he said
meant that hamas was an organization
capable of choice
and that it had to be negotiated with to
test what those choices would be as
opposed to being kept out of the
diplomatic tent
these new voices that have joined
in support of calls for hamas to be
brought to the table include former
national security advisers zbigniew
zabrinski and brent scrowcroft and
former u.s ambassador to the un thomas
pickering
bush's former secretary of state colin
powell cautiously voiced his position
saying hamas had he had to be engaged by
american diplomacy because the movement
had won the election that washing had
demanded the palestinian people hold
more recently former israeli foreign
minister [ __ ] benami put his name to a
similar call along with several of those
who played crucial roles in the northern
irish peace process
last week new respected names joined the
cube paul volcker chuck hagel james
wolfensohn and carla hills
france has indicated a willingness to
engage hamas
and london surprise
preparedness for dialogue with the
political wing of hezbollah in lebanon
would appear to be the opening for a
similar deal with the hamas political
wing in the near future
hamas it seems is on a roll
more than arafat and fatter ever could
hamas has proved that it can fight
but it has also demonstrated that it can
hold its fire
the movement still has a foot firmly
planted in resistance
but it has stamped the other firmly in
the democratic political process
hamas refuses to recognize israel but it
has moved its bottom line
it says it can accept a palestinian
state adjacent to a jewish state
the two-state solution that israel's new
prime minister benjamin netanyahu
opposes
and leave to further generation the
question of hamas's provocative claims
to all of the land that became israel
in traveling to the united states this
week i stopped in damascus to interview
michelle for my newspaper
this was the first time for the hamas
leader to be interviewed on the
implications for hamas of the obama
presidency the outcome of the israeli
elections and the aftermath of the gaza
war
amidst all the hope that so many around
the world have vested reasonably or
unreasonably in the obama presidency i
searched for a gesture
however painless or symbolic that hamas
might offer to mark the end of the bush
years
the hamas bunker
is a disconcerting place
on the one hand
it is command and control center for
jihad
a national foreign ministry of sorts a
resistance treasury
on the other it's michelle's family home
whereas teenage children are just as
likely to wander in to take a seat for
the most intense discussions on hamas
options and its operations
michel held forth expansively
negotiating the tripwires of the
diplomatic and political mine fields
that he inhabits daily
he did it with a certainty and a
confidence that verges on bombast
as he lectures the world on how it
should respond to his movement
not the reverse
starting on what he apparently believed
was a conciliatory note
michelle declared hamas to be as strong
as ever after the gaza war
his words however are more likely to be
read here in the u s and in washington
as a challenge
we're willing to open a new page with
the us and europe he began
but as michelle expanded on
this new page theme
it quickly emerged that he believes
hamas has already moved far enough and
that in his mind it was the united
states and the european union that
should be turning a page
obama will continue to repeat the
mistakes of those who went before him
unless there is a marked change towards
hamas
was the message hamas was the message
that michelle wanted to send
hamas will not be taking any new policy
positions he said flatly
my gesture is a readiness on our part to
deal with washington and europe
but they have to be serious about
dealing with us on palestinian rights
michelle then threatened that if israel
was not more amenable in the faltering
egyptian mediated negotiations with his
movement on the release of gilad shalat
the single israeli soldier prisoner held
by hamas
it risked more of its forces being
captured by hamas to give the movement
even greater leverage in its demands for
the mass release of palestinian
prisoners held by israel
arguing that washington and its european
allies needed to abandon their decision
to isolate hamas until hamas agrees to
international stipulations on its
relationship with israel michelle
countered by saying they've been trying
the wrong way and the wrong approach and
it doesn't work
his view was that there was little value
in appointing the experienced northern
irish peace broker george mitchell as
u.s envoy to the middle east
if he was not to be authorized to talk
to hamas
would he have succeeded in belfast
michelle demanded to know
if he had been ordered to ignore the ira
michelle's strategy is to give little
ground on what to now have been
non-negotiable western demands as a
precursor to any dialogue
regardless
of how far he says hamas has moved
already his language remains steely
combative even
he was contemptuous of secretary of
state hillary clinton's ready acceptance
of the demands of the bush
administration that hamas renounce
violence recognize the state of israel
and abide by all the previous
undertakings on behalf of the
palestinian people
not surprisingly michelle vehemently
disagreed with clinton's warning that
international donations for the
reconstruction of gaza had to be kept
out of what she described as the wrong
hands
for which read hamas
and he ridiculed the seeming
contradiction in her invitation to iran
to attend a regional conference on the
future of afghanistan
at the same time as she shuns hamas
on the grounds that not only is it a
terrorist group but as mrs clinton put
it one that increasingly is a client of
iran
so michelle argues despite a new
presidency there is no change in
attitude in washington they refuse to
accept the results of the palestinian
election because hamas won he says
that failed
they resorted to imposing a siege on the
gaza strip he says
that failed
then they went to war against the
palestinians he says and that failed
despite all this he continues hamas has
advanced and grown
so within the logic of real politic it
is washington that must reconsider its
position if it wants to achieve an
outcome that is not another failure
these were high end issues inevitably
they would be confronted in the
diplomatic bear pit
but i still wanted michelle's take on a
gesture that hamas might make
unilaterally
one that could serve two purposes
one
to give the obama administration room to
reciprocate if only symbolically and two
at the same time to spike the guns of
some of hamas legion of critics around
the world
this is the issue of the hamas charter
and its implacable rejection of the
right of the state of israel to exist
this is one that michel has the power to
settle if he chooses
the charter is rife with offensive
language anti-semitism and incitement to
war to eliminate the state of israel
the reality here is that the policy
changes by hamas
in the intervening years have rendered
these elements of the charter redundant
a point that michel acknowledges
obliquely
but the continued inclusion of the call
to destroy israel is a vulnerable
pressure point as much as it is a
barrier to support from some quarters
which otherwise are sympathetic to the
plight of the palestinians
michelle has dug in
notwithstanding a move a few years back
to redraft the charter which was
pigeonholed in a fit of peak after the
west rejected hamas election win in
2006.
to that extent michelle has become more
hardline
not less so
i pressed the point
would the charter be rewritten not a
chance he replied telling me judge us by
what we are today
not by what was written 20 years ago
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much we have about 20
minutes for questions and a lot of
questions first one is quite
straightforward as a professional
journalist do you believe the us media
is biased in its coverage of this
conflict
i don't like casting judgment on fellow
journalists so i won't
what i will say is that
one of the difficulties of telling
the endless permutations of the
middle east crisis story is that people
resort to shorthands and when they do
they inevitably
choose shorthand descriptions or
descriptors if you like that are put in
the
debate by the spin merchants on both
sides of the crisis
so we talk about muhammad abbas as
moderate
what that means is he's a friend of
washington
it doesn't address the issue of his
corruption of his failure to reform
the policy and organization and the
politics of his movement
we talk about
hamas as extremist but we don't talk
about
the
work the incredible work on the ground
that hamas has done for the people of
the occupied territories where in the
absence of
any
genuine government services it has
raised money around the world in huge
amounts and provided incredible service
to its people yes by most accounts by
most analytical accounts 10 percent of
that money goes to the military wing of
hamas the kazam brigade but it has shown
the work of hamas on the ground social
services work on the ground is so good
that many of the
international ngos un bodies in gaza in
particular when they want to find out
what the real situation is on the ground
they happily consult
hamas because hamas figures are deemed
to be the most believable
in your book you do an excellent job of
contrasting uh
the islamists uh and the secular
folks this question asks about that so
could you elaborate a little bit on
those
those two definitions and uh are all
hamas members islamists
um no they're not um
before they're islamists they are
nationalists
hamas
under the cradle of sheikh ahmed yasin
formed a belief that israel defeated the
arab armies in the six day war because
the arab nations had to varying degrees
failed to adhere to their religion
the israelis
had stuck the jewish community had stuck
with their religion and their beliefs
and that had empowered them to win
his view was that
before the palestinians could
regain
their land they had to regain their
religion so within hamas there is a
significant
religious underlay religious foundation
to their platform but analysts from here
to washington to london to paris to
jerusalem to jordan
spend hours almost on a daily basis
arguing over whether hamas is
more religious than it is more
nationalist and invariably they cannot
agree
i met a
an american analyst in the us
sorry i met an american analyst in
jordan a few years ago who came away
from one of his
secret meetings in those days people
still had secret meetings with hamas
because it was considered subversive
he came away from his third meeting with
khalid michal and his response was it's
the third time he literally was
scratching his head he says the third
time that i've met him he still hasn't
mentioned the quran and he still hasn't
mentioned islam
um fata
is secular
hamas
is fundamentalist
in terms of its fund its basic beliefs
but when you try to ascertain the cause
of change on the ground in hama in gaza
particularly since it has been under the
control of hamas you get
you get a cancer that stop short of
saying hamas is dictating that there be
change
go back to the first interfaith in
1987 through to the early 1990s
it was simply deemed inappropriate in
the occupied territories to have cinemas
functioning to have dancing at weddings
to have liquor and they very quickly
disappeared off the
palestinian social calendar they were
deemed simply to be inappropriate
more recently i spent time on the ground
in gaza
after the uh
what we call the civil war of 2007 when
gaza when hamas took control of gaza
and talking to
it's quite interesting the sources that
you can go to to get the information you
want to find out about
what women feel about their dress or the
best thing to do is to go to the tailors
so you talk to the tailors what's
happened to hemlines in gaza well
hemlines were always low in gaza
although i have to say that i've
interviewed several people who fondly
remember
days on the beaches gaza in the 1960s
and talking of women wearing bikinis
but traditionally
by custom now women wear very low
hemlines but in the aftermath of the
hamas taking control the hemlines
dropped by about two inches
now there was no edict
it was a
i suppose it was a
we talk about journalist self-censoring
it was a an act of
by the community to
go that way
even more interesting was the debate
about facial hair
it sounds absurd to be standing here
talking about the significance of facial
hair
but
fundamentalists don't shave their face
they just grow let their hair grow it
can be very untidy i have to say khaled
bashar wears a very neat trimmed beard
but the fundamentalist
exercises ragged hair most secular
palestinians settle for a moustache
now again
where do you go for the information go
to the barbers the hairdressers
and their view again was no edict no
instruction and there was a this process
of aji bhaji
of debate mostly in the chair between
customers and barbers where they finally
agreed on a style of beard which was
called the sword
and it was just a very fine line of hair
running along the ridge of the chin to
the middle
and the sword is the way to go
if humanitarian aid is unable to get
into gaza is there a way of pressuring
the egyptian and israeli governments to
open the borders for that purpose
you would like to think there was
but if the pressure is not coming from
washington
it's probably not going to work coming
from where anywhere else the united
nations i mean it's quite amazing to
think that a single united nations
agency has been devoted to looking after
palestinians on the ground in gaza since
1948. i mean it is more than 60 years
old how long does
how long does it go on from
the deliveries are still slow they're
far too slow
to try to
sensibly spend any of the
billions of dollars that have been
promised for the reconstruction of gaza
there's still no agreement on how gaza
should be reconstructed i made the
mistake of writing a piece as the
days before the end of the january
combat when you could see that it was
definitely going to come to an end i
made the mistake of beginning a piece of
analysis
on the note that here was a victory for
hamas given what had happened the world
could not stand by
without rushing in to address the
humanitarian crisis that was so apparent
so obvious put to one side who was right
who was wrong here were one and a half
million people in dire circumstances and
yet we are still arguing we are still
haggling about whether 50 100 200 trucks
a day is enough
to reconstruct a place that has been
bombed to bits
following up on the distinction between
secular and islamist this
questioner asks or says you appear to
describe hamas and fatah as inherent
enemies but has not israel used a divide
and conquered strategy to
strengthen their dominance over the over
the palestinians it has indeed but uh to
a certain extent hamas and fatah have
played to that by their
their inability to get on they they they
have reached the point the is quite
interesting all the way through the year
the first years of hamas through the
intifada up to through the second
intifada and finally the elections
in the occupied territories in 2006
the big
nut that neither side could crack was
if hamas were to become a member of the
plo and significantly hamas has never
been a member of the plo and still is
not
if hamas was to become a member of the
plo
what representation should it have on
the executive council of the plo hamas
always said it represented about 40
percent
of
palestinian opinion arafat said no way
you can have 12 percent you can have 15
that's it hamas held its view no 40 40
45 that's what we represent
now as the election results came in
what what vote did hamas get 40 45
they
they had an uncanny knowledge of their
own
place in the palestinian body politic
but having come through the election
having
one government in their own right which
was an amazing achievement for a
resistance movement i mean
wreck your brains and try to think about
another resistance movement of that kind
that has one government outright in its
own
in its own way
um
having achieved that
it then
such was the anger in fata fata's
inability
to accept defeat
um
fatter's
sense of entitlement it had been there
for so long and in many ways fatter was
run and arafat was
to blame for much of this fatah was run
just as most of the
autocratic arab regimes are run
snouts in the trough for the family the
friends the tribes uh for the
organization others who weren't
in the network were kept out
that worked for jobs it worked for
running the government it worked for
liaising with the international
community it worked for the spending of
huge international funds
so
such was the anger
that
abbas
on the advice of washington that has to
be said
stripped tried to strip much of the
power out of the uh
the ministries of the
hamas government before it took office
so that it would be less strong so that
all of the power would be invested in
abbas as president
so there is so much hatred so much anger
so much ill will
and yet at the bottom
each side recognizes two things
that it has to do a deal that there has
to be an agreement between them
and perhaps sadly more often than not
they recognize that that deal is too
difficult to achieve at the moment
so yes they are played against each
other but they're playing into israel's
hands on this
really the same question restated given
the factual uh the fractured state of
the various palestinian organizations is
the continued existence of the state of
israel secure
depends on who you ask
if you go to the democrat demographic
argument no
if you go to the demographic argument
that uh says that in as soon as 15 20 25
years there will be an arab majority
in what is now the state of israel and
the occupied territories it's very hard
to see how the jewish state of israel
will be able to argue
that it is the you know the purest
democracy in the middle east it will
cease to be that
and that would be a significant
wound for it
look at it another way one of the
significant achievements of the whole
israel venture
is that since 1940 i have a colleague
a newspaper editor who when she briefs
reporters she says on a particular sort
of story that she wants delivered she
says the hand goes up here give me the
helicopter view
she wants she wants what it looks like
from up here
so if you look from up here
1948
1967 first intifada second intifada
palestinian elections
it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter who's in government in
israel
who's in government in washington
whether there's any sort of peace
process on foot whether there's the
violent interaction of interfada whether
people are talking or not talking
what has happened
between 1948 and the present is
that israel has succeeded not only in
holding what it had
but
what it took
and is holding that too
and notwithstanding the requirements of
the geneva convention has resettled the
occupied territories with its own people
has increased the
scope of those settlements vertically as
we say and horizontally has increased
the mileage of roads linking them has
increased the number of checkpoints that
limit palestinian movement around them
so
in terms of
setting up the state of israel
and the famous words of ben gurion after
the declaration of independence that we
shouldn't worry about establishing
borders now because we don't know how
far we're going to be able to push them
out
that's still an ongoing operation and to
that extent israel is winning
but whether it can sustain itself in its
winning
is a moot point i mean i often i often
see the israelis and the palestinians as
inevitable prisoners of each other
we have five minutes for two important
questions one
the shorter question or the shorter
answer what is the future of hamas
i think hamas is a a viable organization
it's a more viable organization than
fata
um i think fatah has demonstrated again
and again that
it can't
uh survive as it is and it can't change
itself in order to survive and the more
that the west does and the more that
israel does to prop it up um that code
word that you'll see often in media
reports is bolster it we've got to
bolster hamas sorry we've got a bolster
arafat
and
and
mahmoud abbas
but in bolstering him he is humiliated
time and again in the eyes of the
palestinian people he was humiliated
over the retreat to the perimeter of
gaza in 2005 that was a golden
opportunity for the israelis to show
that he was their partner had he been
brought into a a dialogue instead of
attack happening as the result of
unilateral negotiation he might have
been able to present himself as
achieving something for the palestinian
people instead hamas jumped up and down
and said we drove the israelis out
aren't we great and most palestinians
believe that
more recently the provision of weapons
for
his security forces to fight hamas
israel felt obliged to reveal publicly
that they were providing weapons to fata
to fight hamas think of how that went
down in palestinian public opinion
our last question solicits your personal
opinion
is a negotiated settlement of the
palestinian issue to state or otherwise
possible
i have ceased to believe that israel and
the palestinian people can negotiate a
solution themselves i think after 60
years of most unbelievable violence
most unbelievable privation most
unbelievable insecurity amongst israelis
i believe both sides are so punch drunk
now that they're incapable of
agreeing or negotiating a settlement
the only settlement i see coming is one
that would be imposed and i have to say
i don't see that happening anytime soon
we are out of time on on behalf of the
world affairs council and our audience i
would like to thank mr paul nego for
providing us with his thoughts and
insights he has agreed to stay and sign
copies of his book it's excellent i've
read it it not only covers the political
uh
issues he's talked about but it reads
like the spy novel that it is so i would
encourage you to try it out thank you
very much
[Music]
very
is the former editor for the sydney
morning herald he has reported from many
hot spots in the world including
afghanistan and iraq he's the author of
manhattan to baghdad dispatches from the
front line in the war on terror and in
baghdad of reporters war
paul mcgowan is chief correspondent for
the sydney morning herald to read his
reporting visit smh.com.a.u
here at the conservative political
action committee of samuel wertzelbacher
also known as joe the plumber out with a
new book mr wurtzel backer what's your
book about
it's about